in the distant future Earth is governed
by a militaristic regime called the
global Federation of Earth after the
galactic War veterans ousted democracy
this ruling power encourages the people
to join the mobile infantry promising
citizenship in return for their Federal
service I'm doing my part you know it
citizenship grants rights like voting
and procreation that are withheld from
ordinary civilians it turns out that
humanity is now at tense conflict with a
race of Highly evolved insectoid
creatures the arachnids or bugs one of
the planets inhabited by these creatures
kandathu hurs countless meteorites
towards Earth as a result the military
force intends to eliminate kandath in
order to protect Humanity the scene then
cuts to one year earlier and we are
introduced to a high school student
Johnny Rico who is seen attending a
class of Lieutenant rasac as the teacher
talks about democracy's failure Johnny
is busy flirting with his girlfriend and
Carmen ianz after class the couple goes
to check their test results Carmen seems
to have scored a high Mark while Johnny
fails cuz he's an idiot just then he is
approached by his best friend Carl who
asks about the relationship with Carmen
he reveals that a girl named dizzy also
likes him but he wants to stay with
Carmen afterwards the students are
assigned to dissect some large arachnids
in their biology class the teacher
implores that these creatures are
superior to humans for their rapid
reproduction and selfless Instinct
Johnny nonchalantly carves open and
pulls out the creatur zards which only
causes Carmen to feel uneasy and throw
up and disgust after school Johnny Goes
to Carl's house to learn psychic
abilities it turns out the latter has
been practicing them to become a soldier
as the two are chatting Carl's pet
disturbs them so he uses his ability to
send it away he however claims that he
hasn't figured out how to do such
manipulation on humans yet the next next
day Carmen cheers for Johnny during a
rugby match at one point he evades an
opponent Xander leading him to score a
touchdown while the ladder crashes into
the audience Xander gets up with the
help of Carmen and is immediately
Smitten by her the two have a brief
chitchat when he mentions going to Fleet
Academy this excites Carmen since she
aims to attend the academy as well their
conversation is witnessed by Johnny
causing him to be jealous he then vents
his anger on the game ultimately
securing of Victory later at home
Johnny's father confronts him about
signing up for federal service which
involves two years of sacrifice and
uncertain survival He suggests that
Johnny attend Harvard University instead
but the boy remains Resolute I'm too
stupid for that Dad it appears that
Carmen and Carl are enlisting in the
military to attain citizenship which is
why Johnny wants to do the same however
his low grades prevent him from joining
her in Flight School placing him in the
mobile infantry instead while Carl opts
for military intelligence all three of
them then sign for the academy and vow
to remain friends despite being light
years away the very next day Johnny
meets Carmen at the airport as she's
leaving for her training he confesses
his love for her but she hesitates to
respond just then her flight is
announced so she departs after kissing
him one last time a few days later
Johnny also heads for his military
training where he and the rest of the
new recruits are drilled by the brutal
career Sergeant Zim shortly after dizzy
also joins them having requested
transfer to Johnny's unit this is
because she has a massive crush on him I
don't like bugs Johnny but I like your
balls during lunch she tries to talk to
Johnny but he tells her not to tag along
with them she denies joining the unit
because of him but he doesn't believe
her later while taking a group shower a
fellow unit member kitten asks everyone
for the reason why they joined here a
guy named Breen Ridge claims that he
wants to avoid becoming a farmer unlike
his parents while a young woman Diana
wants to enter politics when it's
Johnny's turn dizzy intervenes and
claims that he's here for his love on
the other hand Carmen enthusiastically
proceeds with her training and seems to
be going very well at first she's
assigned to piloting a Corvette
transport ship which she handles very
easily after this she's transferred to
Fleet battle station taond deroga where
she learns that her instructor is none
other than Xander as Johnny's training
begins he demonstrates his exceptional
athletic prowess that eventually earns
him a promotion to squad leader one
evening the entire unit is resting in
their compartment when Johnny receives a
video message from Carmen she informs
him that her training is going really
well and she's very happy with it
however she also has bad news she
reveals her decision to end her
relationship with him due to their
diverging career paths also citing that
she needs to focus on her career AK AKA
Xander she apologizes for the same and
asks him to write back so that they can
remain France this leaves Johnny
devastated because she was the reason
why he enlisted himself in the military
over hearing this his batchmate Ace
tries to comfort him saying that he got
his promotion on his own as days pass by
Carmen continues training with Xander
and quickly acquires Proficiency in
various flight related skills at one
point she proves herself a skilled pilot
when she changes their Navigation course
to a more eff efficient route due to
this she's officially invited to be a
part of the Captain Crew rather than
remaining a trainee Xander congratulates
her for this achievement and notes that
they're a good team their conversation
is abruptly interrupted when they detect
a gravitational shift caused by an
approaching asteroid in a quick move
Carmen skillfully Maneuvers the ship
beneath the asteroid managing to avoid a
collision with only minor damage this
earns her praise from the captain which
makes her happy one day during a
training session Johnny leads his Squad
into a combat situation using live
ammunition amidst this Breen Ridge
complains that his helmet is
malfunctioning so Johnny removes it to
check at the same time di trips when she
gets hit by a laser this causes her to
accidentally fire towards Breen Ridge
killing him on the spot as a consequence
of Johnny's irresponsible action he's
demoted from squad leader and publicly
flogged in accordance with military law
nothing like a good fogging Diana
overwhelmed by guilt decides to leave
the military these events leave Johnnie
disheartened and after some deliberation
he also decides to quit for good while
packing his belongings he receives a
video call from his parents who are
happy to welcome him back home suddenly
he notices parents' house go dark before
the call ends a short while later all
the soldiers watched the news about a
meteor from kandathu hitting Earth
causing widespread Devastation and
claiming millions of lives Johnny and
dizzy are shocked to learn that their
Hometown has been completely wiped out
now that there's no reason left for
Johnny to return home he requests his
commanding officer to resend his
resignation in response Zim tears up the
resignation form accepting him back into
the squad as a result of this sneak
attack Earth declares war against the
Iraq Nets in the next scene the military
infantry arrives at taond deroga where
Johnny reunit with Carmen she wastes no
time and explains that their breakup was
for the best since they're at War right
then Xander steps in and Carmen shares
that they're in a flight team together
misinterpreting this as the reason for
their breakup Johnny opts to walk away
however he is provoked when Xander
insults the Infantry he then gets into a
fight with the douchebag disregarding
his higher rank however the fellow bath
mates quickly separate them before their
commanding officer notices the following
day an invasion force is dispatched to
kandathu while on Route Carmen detects
plasma beams which her Captain
disregards as harmless however these
beams prove destructive exploding
several infantry carrying ships despite
the losses the surviving ships managed
to land on kandathu the soldiers then
rush for an attack and begin firing
towards the gigantic bugs that release
the plasma
beams for the first few minutes the
soldiers are able to kill several bugs
with their rifles and missiles however
they're eventually ambushed by a swarm
of bugs forcing a retreat on the
General's orders in the chaos the
commanding officer is captured and torn
in half while kitten's body is thrown
into Johnny regardless he continues
firing until AB bug stabs him in his leg
realizing that they can't overpower the
arachnid defense the surviving soldiers
get back to the spaceship and return to
taond deroga after the battle the death
toll seems to have reached 100,000
Carmen checks the list of the dead
soldiers and finds Johnny's name which
breaks her down into tears unbeknownst
to her he is in the care of the medical
Squad receiving treatment for his
injuries days later the fully recovered
Johnny dizzy and Ace join a new unit
called the Ruff necks who are recognized
for their High bug kill count when Ace
jokes about their Lieutenant a Corporal
named Birdie punches him claiming that
he was the one who saved their lives
soon Johnny discovers that their
Lieutenant is none other than rasac he's
a veteran of the first bug war several
years earlier who has been brought out
of retirement to lead the group razac
announces his plan to carry out the
second attack emphasizing a Fool Proof
strategy this time the following day the
ru necks initiate their attack by
dropping a series of Bombs over an area
of the bug's Planet incinerating
numerous Iraq Nets after this the
military unit advances for a ground
assault eliminating the surviving
arachnet with gunfire Johnny Squad
directs a missile into a bug hole
Exterminating all of its inhabitants the
commotion results in a gigantic tanker
bug emerging from the ground it shoots
burning acid towards the soldiers
unfortunately melting Bird's right arm
in a courageous move Johnny climbs a
cliff leaps onto the tanker bug and
begins firing upon creating a hole in
its back he drops a grenade inside
causing the bug to explode last time I
saw this I was 12 but I'm pretty sure it
was freaking awesome impressed by
Johnny's Valor the lieutenant promotes
him to Corporal and designates dizzy as
a squad manager later that evening razac
treats the troops with beers and
entertainment kits to celebrate their
first success amidst this dizzy invites
Johnny to dance but he turns her down
seeing this razak advises him not to
pass up on the good things in life
Johnny gives it a thought and goes to
dance with her their moment eventually
turns romantic and they end up making
love in a tent razak's not just a pilot
he's also a fiery hot wingman the
following day the rough nexer ass signed
to investigate an outpost on planet P
while marching through a rough and Rocky
Canyon razak's Communications Sergeant
is carried off by a winged flyer bug but
before it can stab him the lieutenant
shoots the sergeant sparing him a
painful death he announces that he'd
expect anyone in the unit to do the same
for him as well after this Johnny gets
another field promotion to Sergeant and
assumes command of the squad upon
arriving at The Outpost they discover
that the place has already been attacked
they also find a soldier with a hole in
his skull revealing that the bugs have
sucked out his brains shortly after they
are ambushed by thousands of warrior
bugs supported by tanker and flyer bugs
the troops open fire but they are soon
outnumbered Johnny rushes to the
communication tent and Quest Quests for
pickup while the ship is on the way
razac orders a retreat for evacuation
minutes later the ship and Xander open
the door ordering everyone to get inside
during this razac is ambushed from
Beneath The Ground by a tanker bug that
chews off his legs knowing that he won't
survive he orders Johnny to shoot him
which the ladder reluctantly does
following this dizzy throws a grenade
into the tanker bug's mouth exploding it
to death however another bug appears and
stab her with its big pointed Stinger
Johnny and Ace managed to shoot down the
bug before carrying dizzy onto the ship
on their way back to the base dizzy
passes away in Johnny's arms leaving him
in tears meanwhile Xander goes to the
cockpit and informs Carmen that her
ex-boyfriend is still alive this shocks
her but she manages to conceal her
emotions after Dizzy's funeral on a
Starship Johnny and Carmen are joined by
Carl now a high-ranking colonel in
Military Intelligence he reveals that
the rough necks were used as bait to
test a theory initially infuriating
Johnny however the theory has proven
correct the existence of a brain bug
that controls all arach nits Carl now
appoints Johnny as the leader of the ru
necks promoting him to Lieutenant and
instructing him to return to Planet P to
capture the brain bug while heading to
Planet P the following day Carmen's ship
is torn in half by a plasma beam in a
frantic attempt to survive they rush
into Min space pods to abandon the ship
tragically many crew members are pulled
out into space resulting in their
immediate demise furthermore the captain
also gets fatally crushed under a door
Xander and Carmen somehow manage to
reach the Pod and barely Escape before
their ship is completely destroyed
following this they crash land deep
inside the bug Nest several meters
underground they then contact Johnny via
radio revealing their location hearing
this the lieutenant directs his Squad to
proce proceed with their mission while
he Ace and their squadmate Watkins aim
to rescue the stranded Pilots however
it's too late as the two are captured by
the arachnet one being stabbed in the
shoulder while the other in the leg a
short while later the duo is approached
by the brain bug that soon stabs Xander
in his skull and sucks out his brain
when this leader bug comes for Carmen
she cuts off its appendage causing it
great pain just then Johnny and his team
arrive at the scene holding a nuclear
bomb that momentarily scares the aliens
into backing away soon after the brain
bug escapes while the arachnids launch
an attack on them the soldiers open fire
but Watkins gets sliced across the body
during this commotion knowing that he
won't make it he takes the nuclear bomb
and decides to sacrifice his life urging
the rest of them to run once the
arachnids are close enough and the
others have escaped he triggers the bomb
blowing up his own ass as well as the
bgs upon reaching reaching the surface
they discover that the mobile infantry
led by Sergeant Zim has captured the
brain bug Carl uses his psychic ability
to read the brain bug's mind and
announces that it's afraid of his
captors bringing great joy to everyone
for their success with the brain buug in
custody Military Intelligence begins
studying it to understand how to defeat
its entire race on the other hand Carmen
is now promoted to Captain leading her
own ship while Johnny continues to lead
the rough necks in their mission to
eradicate the threat completely
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching